après seulement 83 matchs à la barre du
canadien le règne de dominique ducharme
est terminée à montréal est satisfait
des performances de l'équipe le nouveau
directeur général qu'un tube choisi de
lui montrer la porte mercredi
le tricolore est après tout en page 2
signé la pire saison de son histoire il
n'a gagné que huit de ses 45 matchs
depuis le début du calendrier s'il a
connu la victoire qu'une seule fois
depuis le 16 décembre les contre
performances de l'équipe faisait
visiblement sur le moral des joueurs qui
est un changement était devenu
nécessaire une solution ne suivait plus
avait plus d'énergie et l'on pense que
nouvelle voie va peut-être réussir à
restructurer un peu le coup
dominique ducharme avait été nommé à la
barre du canadien de façon intérimaire
en février 2021 sous sa gouverne le
tricolore est parvenu a causé la
surprise en séries éliminatoires en
atteignant la finale de la coupe stanley
pour la première fois depuis 1993 l'été
dernier
cette saison son équipe aura toutefois
été victimes du mauvais sort le
capitaine chez wever a pris sa retraite
de façon inopinée et le gardien de but
carey price n'est pas encore revenu au
jeu après avoir eu recours aux
programmes d'assistance des joueurs de
la lnh et une avalanche de blessures les
éclosions que v2 pouvait imaginer
n'importe quelle catastrophe qui imagina
bhl ça s'est abattue sur le canadien
cette saison alors dominique ducharme
n'est pas vraiment à blâmer pour la
performance de son équipe mais on voyait
les joueurs ont abandonné seulement
quelques heures après avoir annoncé le
congédiement de ducharme l'organisation
a nommé martin st-louis comme entraîneur
chef par intérim des canadiens d'ancien
joueur âgé de 46 ans a obtenu plus de
1000 points dans la ligue nationale de
hockey et remporté la coupe stanley en
2004 avec le lightning de tampa bay il
s'agit d'une nouvelle direction pour
l'organisation qui tente de relancer sa
saison il se rappelle qu'il mettra du
canada montréal